みんなわー
うかね好きかいわれわれ人間をとりまのものがいろいろある中我々人間には
この社会で生きるためには大切なものがある
そうのものを買うための
お金だなお金が好きな人と嫌いな人はいないと
ただそのお金をどう使うか他ねは時に人を止めに夫し時にはひとすくいかねからかなぜ
様々なことが今もなんかね
今回は人間を使ったサイエンスどうか人は米の前にお金が落ちていると
どういう反応するのか塗料今日は実際に確かめてみようと思っている
久しぶりなんですけど僕が問わずの匠副社長今から家に来るんですけども
駐車増にン車を止めるんですよ駐車場にこちら
3万円があっあーっにいろんなもございますからねスクとゲート玩具お菓子と味噌
エーカーミランダカー
レベルの同管内3万円が駐車場にポンと置いてありますこれを見つけた時彼はどういう
反応するか愛在ん奴ってことを俺は知っている台がお金を目の前にすると人は
変わるんだぜちょっと彼には申し訳ないんですけども
事務所に3前を置いてそれをどうするかそして後ろなく白拾わなかった金はなかった
その後は俺ん家に行って上にまず何を話すか彼が悪いえって言いたいわけじゃないん
ですよもしお金があるとそれに目をクランでこのパコ財布に入れるかもしれないよその
まま俺に落ちて打球かもしれない
というわけで効果
ブーブー言っは
のでん
いい
wh
ええええええ
たですね
考えを持っ
木
voodoo
てなんかあるかどうか
今回はないですよ
銀杏の木うそえっ
ああああああ
rar
おねっと思いてあるんだけど
ベッツィー具材を素通りした
すごい少ないかと思っ
wh
ですっジャガー絶好オーニングがどっじゃないよね
彼はこれからいい人でしたありがとうございました
あああああ俺だったらすぐと言うよね
しています